So remember that in the last quiz you
simplified y to the fourth x squared y to
the negative two to equal x squared y
squared. But in doing these we actually
dealt with something we haven't talked
about explicitly before. This negative
exponent right here. My question for you
now is basically what do negative
exponents mean? So which of these five
answers down here. Is an equivalent
expression to what we started out, with y
to the fourth x squared y to the negative
two? Remember whatever you pick down here,
also needs to give us the final answer of
x squared y squared in the end. So think
about what intermediate step you need
between here and here. And which one of
these answer choices fits that? This is
definitely a little bit tricky.